[Music]
in silent ship news one submitted by
Julio's blue hair it's not blue no more
not me that's why it's a minute because
it's not here anymore it has a mind of
its own
if they're firing ship of Game of
Thrones okay cruise passengers were
ordered to switch off lights and music
for ten days due to the threat of a part
attack oh my god so the entire life of
the cruise ship which is off for the
ocean what [ __ ] that is fun to hell no
it's fine do they smell the pizza
buffets oh yeah yeah because if that
piece of Luffy is running yeah yeah it's
kind of hard to be skinny and living on
a cruise ship it's just a buffet all the
time yeah did you have breakfast like
the breakfast buffet book oh yeah a
slice of pizza like every four hours but
when I left when we left today we had to
wake up early to the breakfast buffet
was good back then everything Newton
like it was crazy Frenchman said mental
yeah like straight up continental
waffles pancakes everything each other
so this cruise ship this Princess Cruise
reenlist of the free physicals so this
is a a 104 day around the world cruise a
hundred four days you've got no time to
go to work I bet you it's all senior
citizen
yeah has to be that's like three months
yeah three months shrine on a boat you
ain't getting no [ __ ] on that they've
departed from Sydney there's a 40,000
dollar triple passengers paid bait right
if it's up 40,000 that means that's like
that's a different type of cruising
because that one must be like up there
then 40 now because crews aren't that
expensive $4,000 a day yeah that's a
ball and a screws then no it's 400 a day
100 is Lauren bill that's crazy
this is the princess I want to see what
the inside the line where were they in
the ocean where they couldn't like
notify the local Coast Guard to protect
them where they had to just
shut down the lights on their own they
must have been away some deep-sea area
where it's like completely off the coast
the ship was travelling across the
Indian Ocean and the Arabian Sea or Gulf
of Aden and Suez come out so this is
Memphis Indian Coast Guard come and
protect them go on do it that's right
that's right next to Somalia that's
where all the Pirates are my entire life
guys are unknown I think those cruise
ships should be allowed to have Gatling
guns so they could just blast the [ __ ]
out of people that try to Kimani they
should sail across there like yeah away
from there as I'm saying when they were
compact Indian don't do it have a what
what are you doing don't do it it
doesn't increase house of decency
captain ordered a dusk till dawn
blackout due to a very real pirate
threat I'll come to this pirating is
such a big thing and Somali I do like
the high school counselors really pushed
that there why is it only Somalian
pirates what about the neighbouring
countrymen is kind of gone and there's
no industry so they used to fish but I
think the water still is a huge oil
spill they can't work anymore
absolutely the characters from that Tom
Hanks man captain Phillips yeah so
there's used to being on the sea and
another of the converted from fishermen
they're all fishermen turned pirates
yeah that makes sense okay and then
there's also other countries coming in
you Eagle II fishing in their waters
because their government can do we hold
it down so they're just stealing all the
fish so lose 1900 passengers they had to
have all their curtains drawn they had
to turn out all the lights no music no
deck parties no movies Under the Sun or
stars so you know how like there are
huge movies dream was 10 days 10 D what
about the club
nothing's go on dancer this stuff Oh
what about the casino maybe isn't this
more like indoors and no windows there
there's no windows I bet you was popping
there though okay how would you want to
play knowing that you might be under
attack I know I could be scared for one
day and then after that my [ __ ] let's
get the pizza in the ice cream and go to
casino pirates are going to raid my boat
I want the Jack Sparrow looking ones I
don't want the Somalian ones why do you
want to pick
yeah I want the eye patch and the
[ __ ] Buccaneer kind of like I want
them to come back from the past huh
you're like hold on I have a costume I
like horror you know I want those kind
of pirates like I don't want I don't
want the Somalian ones I'm sorry what if
they're dressed like that
the Somali I mean maybe I could work
with this okay but they got to do the
whole like higher you know I don't want
like the Somalian X I think I don't know
which one I was in passenger I would
have no qualms of trying to murder
somebody if there was a pirate coming on
but I wouldn't think I would feel guilt
murdering a pirate or another passenger
a pirate problem is they're pirating cos
of I mean that's all they have that's
all they're high understand but I don't
have sympathy for somebody who's trying
to rob and pillage me yep I agree I'm
running straight to the kitchen grabbing
nice that's exactly what I was thinking
chef knives they really something rowing
trick your kitchen get some pizza yeah
both yeah nice people arming myself like
I want them to like come onboard and
then I DS [ __ ] are crazy you
know and they're gonna think twice about
it the caption was like assuring
everyone there that they could outrun a
pirate ship they also have precautions
like powerful hoses to not pirates off
the ladders that they'll hook on they
have detergent solution to make the
ladder slippery some home alone [ __ ]
only cars to put on the debts of the
fuck-ups flying around even every
president these are like real solutions
like I thought they were going to talk
about like we have specific technology
that will actually like electrically
shocked him if they try to grab the rail
this is we got some soap some bubble to
the Lego
right when they get back up throw the
legs open up further hand because I'm
pretty sure they got shoes so we just go
put some jacks on the car
the ship is equipped with sonic booms
and not some awful audit both we got guy
on sonic boom but if they can outrun the
ship why do they need this otherwise I
was thinking yeah so I guess if you they
were just telling the passengers that
maybe so column now I don't know I
really don't know how many
you know there in single policy so
they're probably not trying to go forth
oh you're telling me okay if the
captain's like okay we can outrun them
but we don't want it to be a choppy ride
for you I'd be like I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm going to throw up I forget the [ __ ]
out of here I'm doing wheelchairs and
like they're all old and stuff
you're gonna die live in the dirt for
ten days ya know because I'd like run
drills and they'll tell everyone go to
your muster stations right yeah yeah
yeah so then they would advise everyone
to sit on the floor hang on to the
handrails in case the ship has to
maneuver away from the pirate ship they
don't have like security with guns and
[ __ ] on [ __ ] oh god it was so [ __ ]
mad were like they just grabbed us in a
room and they give us these janky-ass
solutions or like this is what we're
going to do this is my secret weapon he
brings out a bag of marbles I watch them
try to run on these come along the whole
ship yeah what if they at the end of the
trip were like guys it was all just
make-believe like we wanted you guys
experienced it you guys can embrace your
family and like enjoy life I give me
back my 40,000 polish there was an
American on that boat I was W got be a
lawsuit Harry what was the pizza bombed
oh I know that people isn't speaking
best pizzas I've ever had you know why
it's because it's fresh oh I think it
was also because it was better than all
the other food that we read about it but
I won't find any place to eat that we
[ __ ] up I didn't know that we could go
to every night you just buy food the
free food on the cruises aren't the good
ones you got to go to the restaurants
are you paid those are pretty holy Lord
sure we all went to and it tasted like
waiting for oh that is a better one
there's a whole area where there's like
a steakhouse a burger house a fine
dining one we went to like our Italian
border so good job
that [ __ ] was [ __ ] good dude [ __ ] up
I would eat there every day so if you go
on a cruise you go for the paying
restaurant you have to pay more actually
a package that I that you can get where
you get that as a voucher for free place
is way more expensive mmm
bobble times next time free food is
sometimes I got to gamble so don't
matter and I don't know if I ever get
raided by pirates I don't know if I'll
befriend them or like if I throw some
like cookies at home so they can heat
like it depends you know like they want
your money and your [ __ ] valuables I
don't know what brings money on a cruise
and probably all the food on the first
Lobby so Maggie took the food see okay
well you're valuable and like grad is
this your wife
yeah now she's my girlfriend but look in
the food but they're just saying any
measures of board sea princess were
simply taken out of an abundance and
caution and not in response to a
specific threat and are common to
international shipping sailing in the
region have you seen videos of how
Russians and like Chinese and all them
respond to like these pirates like like
they don't give a [ __ ] like they just
start seeing the Pirates come and then
they break out the guns and they just
start shooting oh [ __ ] alright these
[ __ ] are real actions crazy
dude yeah I probably wouldn't want to
[ __ ] with the Russian ship dude I don't
think they give two [ __ ] about your
like you and [ __ ] that I see the waiting
to use rocket monster for years you have
any specific laws on water like on
probably the UN there's so the Geneva
Convention on choose you can't use
certain rounds on people and stuff like
that that was right - all the time
hey you guys want to stock any of us
we'll go ahead down to the description
box below and you can follow us on
Instagram and all kinds of stuff for
more videos
[Music]